la suite de la page au sport la
chronique aux sports du lundi nous
accueillons sur le plateau jean
christophe liron bonsoir président du
club de basket de trappes l'étoile
sportive des cheminots de trappes la
saison en nationale 2 va reprendre ce
week-end on va en parler dans un instant
et puis nous avons un autre champion sur
le plateau ce soir
oui tout à fait un champion plutôt
exceptionnel un athlète jean-louis nos
bonsoir bonsoir
votre spécificité c'est que vous êtes le
recordman du monde du 1500 m et vous
avez 60 73 ans je me trompe pas champion
du monde dans ma catégorie
oui dans la catégorie vétérans la
catégorie a déclaré confondues qui a
déjà répondu ça c'est un peu voilà
exactement alors première question c'est
à 60 raison qu'il est votre secret pour
courir aussi vite il ya pas de secret
disons que il faut le parent été pensée
dans une carrière sportive vous arrêter
même un an et vous avez beaucoup de mal
à reprendre
donc en fait c'est celle l'entraînement
un peu continue avec des coupures bien
sûr parfois dures ou blessure
malheureusement mais votre retour c'est
quoi justement votre corps du du 1500 m
c'est cinq minutes 0 3 1 c'est simple
oui c'est en 15 100 m indoor oui en
indoor en 70 ans et plus parce que sinon
mes autres records à l'époque quand on
était senior et c'est bon j'ai pas eu
des résultats extrêmement brillant parce
que je m'étais pas préparé non plus une
à l'allemand wifi fier alors du coup
aujourd'hui vous pouvez tous les jours
c'est impossible de nom parce que djian
que faut ménager sa monture qu'on m'a
dit et beaucoup ne sont plus là en
vétérans cap parce que ils ont fait des
150 km par semaine sans arrêt en course
à pied puis ils ont les genoux fichu les
cartilages usées non moi j'ai changé
j'ai relativement ménager sa monture et
vous avez une alimentation particulière
où vous avez un régime particulier non
non je fasse je suis un peu prudent moi
j'ai tendance à voir du cholestérol donc
j'évite les graisses mais sa sérénité
et puis on peut manger équilibré mais
par contre maintenant à mon âge mais on
fait du sport on va dire corps etc
mais on se permet quand même de faire
bonne chère donc jésus des bons repas
je vous en convient mais comme les
apéritifs et repas trop contente ça va
contre un don vous allez nous dire qu'en
fait vous pourrez très vite vous êtes
encore mal mais tout ça c'est très
facile à obtenir
je pourrais encore les +86 jeu si
j'avais un régime plus strict mais si je
m'entraînais plus spécifiquement et ses
environs qui fait du basket club de
trappes ça vous impressionnait ce que
vous avez des athlètes de ce niveau là
dans les catégories vétérans bastian par
exemple oui mais je me souviens qu'on
avait monsieur pour pas le citer claude
shônen qui est qui a joué en équipe
vétérans jusqu'à l'âge de pareilles 70
72 ans et qui avait encore une bonne
forme et d'ailleurs je pense à lui s'il
est venu nous voir jouer dimanche
pour notre première victoire à lord
ancien et j'ai pensé à lui en écoutant
me suis donc on peut aussi jouer au
basket à cet âge là oui ça fait bon
c'est sûr pas le même effort parce que
c'est 1500 m c'est plus un travail
foncier le basket c'est plus sur des
courses rapides d'alterner donc c'est un
effort un peu différent mais qui peut
être plus dangereux basket que la course
de fond parce qu'il sait des efforts qui
sont plus dynamiques
on va dire que c'est pratiquer
différents sports justement oui moi je
commence sa bd en scolaire beaucoup j'ai
fait du basket du tennis le ski je me
suis mis très tard cette grosse entorse
au ski alors c est bon je sais sport
collectif mais donc jusqu'à l'âge de 25
ans comme après étudiants ou et ensuite
pour pour vraiment percé il faut se
spécialiser dans faire vraiment
l'athlétisme la course à pied après il
ya trop de risques aussi avec le tennis
vous notamment des glissades sur les
tendons d'achille ça peut être mortel
mais alors vous avez le record du monde
donc en indoor du 1500 m mais vous avez
aussi un très beau palmarès puisque vous
avez une belle moisson médaille prix
dont une toute petite quantité qui est
ici je crois petite ville les présentait
justement cette médaille parce qu'il y
en a tellement
s'agissant des médailles avant sur piste
parce que je me suis remis à une ou deux
pour nous montrer un petit peu certains
voulaient prendre
ouais parce que ça donne envie en fait
de les avoir aujourd'hui je me suis
remis à la piste
justement tu angèle avoir 70 ans j'avais
arrêté à la piste vers 50 en effet après
que dure ce stade c'est donc course à
pied marathon bien spéciale et un
marathon et là je suis revenue sur la
piste en soixante dix ans ça me redonne
de la vitesse alors et donc ma première
année bain des tirs en 4ème et teyran
m70 près de vous alors c'était en
hongrie
ça c'était la première médaille c'est
les trois médailles d'or et une médaille
d'argent en gris c'est le première
médaille internationale parce que là où
je suis allé aux championnats d'europe
en stade là c'était un nigiri d'sa en
gris non ça c'était les premières en
2010 il ya deux ans et donc j'avais
parcouru 2 800 m depuis 25 ans et là je
gagne le le 800 m en 2 minutes 30
secondes
donc j'avais encore garder des bonnes
notes tactiques stratégiques voler vos
médailles si vous permettez par exemple
celle ci voilà on va sortir parce que ça
si c'est la médaille d'or voyez c'est la
médaille d'argent du voilà très jolie
médaille avec laquelle devaient repartir
ça brille beaucoup c'est très joli mais
l'argent du 1500 m à sacramento 2011
c'est l'été 2011 en plein air et là j'ai
été battus enfin par le champion
roberson est intouchable et la champions
nos landes est d'ailleurs qu'il a
pulvérisé tous les records de
du monde m 70 kg en a qui sont meilleurs
que vous quand même pas dire il était un
peu plus jeunes face à mana parce que on
est par catégorie en maintenant de 55
ans dont 70 74 75 donc là maintenant moi
je vais rentrer déjà en janvier en 4e
année donc il ya les jeunes comme on
dira qu'ils arrivent ou montcoy quelle
compétition à laquelle vous n'avez pas
encore participé vous aimeriez faire vos
projets c'est quoi maintenant dans le
long jamais fait le 24 heures mais je le
ferai pas monsieur reto aux 100
kilomètres en course sur route
bon oui je vais je vais tout tenter je
joue c'est bon un peu le trail mais
qu'est ce que vous avez à peu près
toutes les médailles
par contre c'est juste que j'ai refait
cette année non pour m'amuser j'ai jaffe
les 1 400 m aux championnats de france
puis au chaud aux pieds au championnat
de championnats d'europe cet été je fais
le 400 m je n'ai jamais fait en
compétition et là j'ai quand même fait
mon 69 secondes mais s'en sort
préparation spéciale sage pour vous
amuser voilà non seulement rester avec
nous on va parler des autres athlètes de
la catégorie vétérans oui tout à fait
véronique augereau justement qui est une
marcheuse et une marcheuse d'exception
puisque elle récolte aussi beaucoup de
médailles 22 depuis depuis 2005 toutes
compétitions confondues en
internationale et nous avons voulu la
suivre
lors de sa reprise entraînement
marché je mets les seuls les kilomètres
face à la souffrance c'est désormais le
quotidien de véronique cochereau
assistante de direction dans la vie
professionnelle marcheuse d'exception
sur la piste véronique est un cas à part
dans l'athlétisme
ce n'est qu'en 2005 qu'elle pose ses
empreintes dans le monde de la marche et
la découverte devient vite une addiction
la marche est une drogue parce que ça me
manque dès que je peux pas m'arrêter
très longtemps je sais pas ce qu'on
estime jonna lee mais c'est une ces deux
nuls de rang dans les faits oui parce
que la plus souillée j'étais blessé je
la seule question je me suis posée
est-ce que je vais pouvoir continuer en
2010 véronique se retrouve sans
entraîneur bernard coadou le patron de
la piste à montigny du propose ses
services
ces progrès sont alors fulgurant en 2012
véronique bas trois records personnels
glane 10 médailles dont trois aux
championnats d'europe en août dernier à
raison de quatre entraînements
hebdomadaires
lenny monteyne ont enfilé km mais
parfois avec un peu trop d'engouement à
l'entraînement elle est toujours là
et elle donne toujours le maximum à
l'entraînement
des fois où foule à laquelle mais un peu
parce que ça va toujours un peu trop
vite parfois un petit manque de
confiance en elle
elle a toujours peur de ne pas être
prête elle se pose toujours des
questions
oui mais est-ce que c'est bien ça pour
l'entraînement qu'il faut faire oui mais
oui malgré ses performances
la marcheuse unis montrent elle ne
reçoit aucune aide de la fédération
française d'athlétisme frais
d'engagement des compétitions
hébergement jusqu'au survêtement
tricolore véronique finance tout malgré
les récentes performances de yoann diniz
l'athlète du smac regrette que son sport
ne soit pas reconnu à sa juste valeur et
pas reconnu
je sais que souvent quand je sors je me
fais moquer de moi dans la rue et ccc
une c'est dur parce que les gens sont
pas construits c'est comme les forces
c'est violent et quand on me dit souvent
débattu vous feriez mieux de courir vous
auriez fait non je tournais en rond ce
km heure il rend ce que metref c'est
rare que mais en cours en irak elle
n'arrive même pas et véronique partage
sa passion avec sa fille de retour sur
les pistes depuis deux saisons basse a
toujours été un plaisir après j'ai eu
quelques soucis donc j'ai dû arrêter et
puis bah avec les médailles de normand
ça donne toujours plus ou moins envie à
53 ans véronique cochereau ne se fixe
pas de limites
son plus beau rêve faire retentir la
marseillaise sur un podium international
alors jean louis henno justement
qu'est-ce que quel regard portez-vous
sur baïse marcheuse comme comme
véronique au chaud ce qu'on sait que la
marche est un petit peu particulier
comme comme sport c'est particulier moi
je le déhanchement c'est pas s'est pas
restreint très naturel le marche
athlétique et le problème là dessus
c'est qu'il faut pas aller à la faute
c'est très difficile de ne pas courir ou
pas et puisqu'il faut garder les gens de
ton gioia vers le espère être en
suspension donc là c'est très efficace
nous les coureurs on aurait tendance à
accélérer un peu trop rire et donc mais
c'est quand même un sport qui est peu
reconnu
c'est ce que dit on y va ce mail en dix
ans et potages depuis quelques temps
comme c
sa figure dans les interclubs
d'athlétisme depuis peut-être pas très
longtemps m'a peut-être une dizaine
d'années et avancent donc ça oblige
maintenant les clubs à avoir des
démarcheurs forme et surtout pour les
interclubs
il faudra voir de marcheurs par par
équipes
donc c'est pas évident